[Music]
so in bad career move news oh yes
everyone here we mean you know it I made
the best career I made the best career
move I would have been a doctor can you
imagine that yeah [ __ ] selfish this
was submitted by Bart farts cures cancer
it does what's crazy
I [ __ ] razors every night make me
question the friendship right well you
don't know that so Conor McGregor has
been in hot water after being charged
with assault yeah
during a public altercation I don't get
it
idiot what's all you get I get it I
don't care what all you get um I don't
get that he like has finally made this
crazy breakthrough right like he he
became a household name yeah 100 million
dollars yeah yeah and then he does this
[ __ ] like I get why he did it like I
mean as a fighter because money does not
change the person it only heightens who
they actually are yep so how the Scotty
got money now he's supposed to be classy
yeah everybody
garol still everybody gadelle sale so
it's kind of interesting like how this
all started off so artem is like Connors
training partner so whenever they spar
he fights with Artem Artem was on tough
if you guys watched the Ultimate Fighter
series where they kind of get some they
get a new Ultimate Fighter to come in
all right him has great hands his record
is [ __ ] his [ __ ] it's like 14 losses
and 13 wins hooked of so he's like his
nickname is like the hammer cuz his
[ __ ] hands aren't hot but everything
else he sets it wait what was his record
that sounds crazy 14 losses lost from
like 13 wins or something like that it's
half and half basically it might be
worse now that's pretty bad
however habib comes up to him and so
artem was interviewed like by a russian
interviewer basically he was talking
[ __ ] about could be saying he was
ducking connor calling him a [ __ ] and
all these other [ __ ] words
and so kobe literally comes up to him
and I'm gonna use a Joe as an example
and this is the most gangster [ __ ] I've
ever seen in my life so Kobe was talking
to me he goes put his hands on the back
of his head like this he goes you call
me a [ __ ] [ __ ]
like this oh yeah looking in gachi [ __ ]
and he was translate he was like did you
call me a [ __ ] [ __ ] right he goes no
all raping him yeah he was like no I did
it he goes he goes that's not what you
said you called me a [ __ ] [ __ ]
did he have his white hat on so he's
literally grabbing him in the back of
the [ __ ] necks there in his eyes and
so uh Connor like flew in just to [ __ ]
up like Habib because that situation
they also ganged up it was khabib and
his crew and and there's footage in the
hallway they're all surrounding him yeah
it's like the most frightening [ __ ]
thing I mean I guess like the cool thing
was like literally like when they were
translating it could be it was telling
everybody to back off he just wanted to
talk him one-on-one he told him like but
then they surrounded him you just want
to talk to Connor one-on-one no he won't
not the art of art of art him was
talking that [ __ ] about him in like a
Russian interview yeah Connor I guess
felt that that was such a [ __ ] move
because it's like why are you ganging up
on my friend
and intimidating him and then they're
just like come out and let's just
[ __ ] handle this but he wasn't even
saying come on he pretty much crashed
the media event and then he that's when
he took a dolly and threw it to the bus
where it could be wasn't so I'll show
you guys that clip right now this [ __ ]
went viral I have to say though the way
he threw that dolly I was like wow
that's cool I threw a [ __ ] dolly that
she just goes [ __ ] to the ground yeah
like she launched that [ __ ] like it was
a [ __ ] sick year yeah it looked like
Spri he is he went straight to dolly and
he went very great artist very great he
pretty much [ __ ] up your RCT michael
Chiesa he got scratched in the face you
ugly ray borg I think he had like some
like name she was supposed to fight -
but she got scarred or traumatized or
something who something like that she
was in the bus - but then she was like
so shaken by the event which I rose I
think it was rose she was the one that
said like she KC was telling me that she
was gonna back out of the fight because
of it like you've just [ __ ] with her
whole psyche like yeah yeah yeah finding
the cage though yeah that's where I left
off I didn't I didn't know cuz Rose
actually almost got hit by the dolly so
if that metal bar wasn't that it would
have [ __ ] her up - she would've been
out so it was it was pretty bad and I'm
I think like they have like multiple
lawsuits against it because those
fighters didn't get paid yeah I'm just
gonna get super [ __ ] sued yeah so
right now as a person and they know he
got a hundred mil yep from that
Mayweather and everything else so as of
right now he's charged with three counts
of assault and one count of criminal
mischief or any of these felonies for
good question okay
he just got charged so he didn't get
convicted yet yeah but if he does would
it be I don't know on the state they
charge him in the van kid if they could
get him for assault with a deadly weapon
then then he's a yeah but then like it
just depends on what they want to attack
them with oh the lawyers are gonna go in
it's like possible seven units or
something like that yeah
typically is treated as a misdemeanor
not a felony for assault
I don't know cuz he got a lot of money
so that might change the game like they
might go after so much money and
everything but also how cool was that
dolly though though it was who do you
think the UFC like that whole team comes
in with their lawyers to to protect I
guess no they're not gonna do it Danis
[ __ ] with Dana's money yeah event yeah
and then a lot of people are asking or
speculating like oh is this all staged
that's what I thought but then Dana
himself he was like this is like the
furthest thing from a stunt like this is
[ __ ] everything up like there's no
way we would stage this [ __ ] cuz it
doesn't create more money for the US
yeah it makes people not want to watch
it yeah it reinforces the stereotype cuz
they already think it's human
cockfighting yeah they already think
it's a bunch of heathens just throwing
it down not treating it as like good
sportsmanship and and like a sport and
then so now it's just reinforcing like
all the 10 20 years at the UFC has been
trying to do we're like trying to help
Brett a better Brandon market it this is
an actual sport it's just going
backwards yeah my conspiracy ass thought
this is what happened he learned a
little how to like stir up drama from
Mayweather cuz they're like homies now
and then like he's gonna stir up draw
between him and Kobe and then when they
finally fight that's gonna be a blow out
of bed oh yeah but then I also heard
that Conner and Mayweather was gonna do
a UFC kind of thing yeah but then that
got cancelled yeah they were planning a
corner and Mayweather fight inside the
cage but was that kind of like boxing
rules a little bit of punching and then
I think day know I came out and said
that was a Conor did kind of ruined the
whole thing
Conor Logan pulled himself yeah baby
what do you want it to do No
always slamming chairs slamming
something as a somebody who's like who
watching UFC for a very long time that
makes me not wanna watch the UFC yeah
it's like I don't want to see them I
want to see people like paying it off I
want to see that well I would watch the
W effort W be no support McGregor well
they're all [ __ ] brutes and dumbasses
because the reason why that's important
to like well he's down for his homie
listen here you [ __ ] dumb [ __ ] this
is they're adults there's money involved
it's not about backing up your [ __ ]
homie if you wanted to whup his ass stop
being a [ __ ] [ __ ] and ducking the
[ __ ] fight and get in the [ __ ]
cage yeah I really think that's what it
is at this point because if he's talking
about oh I don't need the [ __ ] money
I'm all about being a fighter he's
you've been ducking this guy for a long
time I don't give a [ __ ] what anybody
says if he says that he's such a [ __ ]
warrior just like that's like his whole
motto right I'm a [ __ ] warrior I'm
the best [ __ ] finite well there's a
guy right here that said they say it is
the best [ __ ] lightweight in a very
long time he wants to fight you but no I
don't have the time for it no I got this
other [ __ ] to do doesn't really make
sense because that means you're not
about fighting you're more about
whatever money or whatever yeah there's
like three or four guys lined up to
fight him and they would all make really
really great fights but he's been
ducking on for a year yeah yeah he got
shipped about damn straight because he
has a for all reason far so when your
champion it's your responsibility to
defend your belt and put on the fights
that people want to watch so people want
to see the champion get challenged over
and over but if you're not putting on
fights and if you haven't fought in over
a year then they have every right to
take it away
what does I mean the last fight with
coop even the New York dude does he get
about they're gonna be been all Al Ahly
Quentin or whatever so that they
stripped the belt and now the belt is up
for grabs for those two and it could be
beat him so could be Eve now has the
belt Oh cuz I read something about um
the Quincy he couldn't even qualify for
the you couldn't qualify cuz he [ __ ]
up he didn't make weight yeah so New
York the New York Gaming Commission
wasn't gonna grant him the belt but the
UFC was gonna grant it to him anyways
yeah so there's like I mean like a lot
of things are going into like the
organization the state laws like there's
like and because the sport is at such a
high level now you want to see sportsmen
like good sportsmanship so [ __ ] like
this kind of sets the sport back I think
if I was 13 and I saw that [ __ ] I'll be
like [ __ ] yeah McGregor you know bit
but now at my age like once you pass
that 30 mark I really hope that you're
[ __ ] smart enough to realize the
bigger man is the one that doesn't go
out of control and controls his [ __ ]
yeah cuz right after I Gregor through
the dolly at the bus then could be comes
out because they had to take him out of
the bus and I saw him I tell the camera
like dude just come at me just send me a
text let me know where to meet you no
bodyguards no no no USD no cameras but
he was a [ __ ] monster dude he doesn't
give a [ __ ] dude do you hear him he was
like oh I'm gonna [ __ ] him I'm gonna
[ __ ] him up it's like well why you need
camera and people for you I texted you
come up I'd punch you in face a [ __ ]
monster dude he doesn't give a [ __ ]
because a lot of people are saying like
well one could be was so anything
because they wouldn't let him he's at
that point - if you're trying to fight
for a match you're fighting for like a
million dollars or whatever I don't
think that's something that his team
would appreciate his management would
appreciate you know so he's actually
being a lot more level-headed so in his
mind he's like well after all said and
done nobody will be there you all right
we could just Duke it out I don't give a
[ __ ] you know what made me sad was I was
like I thought McGregor was a martial
artist
yeah no self-control homie no that's
kind of been his attitude from the very
beginning if you like see it like if you
watch his documentary he is that guy he
is that flash dude he is the guy that's
like yo I am doing it for the money like
I don't give a [ __ ] about anything else
like I'm not gonna be humble in what I'm
doing
he's a guy that flies out 20 dudes from
Ireland [ __ ] someone else yeah yeah like
since the get he's been like I am that
guy I'm a huge like Conor McGregor fan
so it's like you know me saying that
he's like ducking like Habeeb is not me
like saying that because I'm a huge Kobe
fan I'm a huge Conor McGregor fan he's
actually one of the most exciting
fighters aside from all the [ __ ]
like his skill level yeah looking a
major leaguer it's crazy he's like one
of the best counter strikers in the game
and he's fun to watch but he looks up to
Bruce Lee and then Bruce Lee is looking
down from heaven like you're not like
water man that's why I didn't want to
teach the choir low in the beginning
that's why they told me that they tasted
wine I should have listened to my
[ __ ] Sifu man
[Music]